i'm nick spicer welcome to the program
russia says a total of 1700 ukrainian
fighters have now surrendered at the
azov stall steel plant and mario paul if
confirmed that would be 700 more since
wednesday
moscow says most have been taken to a
prison colony in russian-controlled
territory while the injured are in
hospital these images come from russia's
defense ministry
the international red cross says it has
registered hundreds of prisoners of war
from the steel plant including wounded
fighters keefe hopes to get the soldiers
back in a prisoner swap while moscow has
threatened to put some on trial for war
crimes
our correspondent matthias billinger is
in kharkiv i meantis what more can you
tell us about the hundreds of ukrainian
soldiers at the azov stall steel works
who we here are surrendering today
uh yeah we've heard that the red cross
has registered them as prisoners of war
so there is a record on who who is now
in the hands of the russians but of
course it is not clear uh what is going
to happen then we understand that there
has been an agreement between ukraine
and russia on uh these on an exchange
of these fighters from the steel steel
works
for russian prisoners of war here in
ukraine but um it's very unclear whether
this is going to happen you've just
mentioned the news there are many people
in russia inside the russian
elite or inside the russian government
demanding that they would be somehow
punished that they would be declared
terrorists and so on so russia has now
something in their hands with that they
can
negotiate a very a very um heavy uh a
negotiating power um and uh because
ukraine has said that they want to see
them back alive
zielenski has said he wants
he's trying to save every life of a
ukrainian soldier that he can save and
that's an important thing because this
is one of the things that uh um the
narratives of of the ukrainians in this
war that they don't treat their soldiers
as cruelly as the russians it's
something they've been telling the
people they've been showing the people
how cruel russians are treating their
own soldiers so it's an important it's
important for ukraine to get them back
and that gives russia a lot of leverage
of course and uh you're in kharkiv now
just to shift to to your locale what's
the situation on the ground there
kharkev is still being shelled but it's
now being shelled like other cities with
rockets etc
the artillery is mostly out of range
from the city so um
this constant bombardment of several
some parts of the city we've been to one
part today the northern at the very very
edge of the city where fighting was very
close and there is virtually it's it's
it's a it's a high-rise it's a it's a
settlement with a lot of high-rise
buildings and virtually none of them is
undamaged many of them are burned out
it's hundreds or thousands of
of uh uh apartments destroyed here in
the city it's a bit calmer life is
slowly returning but really slowly we've
also been in a shelter today we've asked
people uh in in a metro station and they
have said they are still afraid to go
out and they actually want to stay in
the metro station although the city
wants to get the metro running again to
get back to a bit a more normal
functioning of the city so but they say
no
they don't want to get out they're
afraid of of going back outside there
many of the houses have been destroyed
so um
it's very it's many people are still
psychologically
suffering from the past they are still
wary about what the situation is now as
we can imagine of course matthias
billing reporting for us from kharkiv